Prince Harry claims he killed 25 people  in Afghanistan but the problem is he  might be lying according to the prince  quote you can't kill people if you see  them as people you have to view them as  chess pieces instead end quote that was  from his new Memoir where he tried to  paint himself as not some spoiled rich  kid born into royalty but a scarred war  hero that you should respect and feel  bad for and while he did serve 10 years  in the British army with two tours in  Afghanistan no one is sure that these  claims are even true not even the  Taliban agrees quote we checked and  found that the days on which Prince  Harry is mentioning the killing of 25  muahedin we did not have any casualties  end quote according to one Taliban  leader but if it is true Prince Harry  may have just put a big Target on his  back will people in Afghanistan try to  get revenge for this ex-army Chiefs are  worried that they might because